[Musique]
ce qui est bien c'est pas vu louis van
persie de l'invitation dès qu'il le peut
daniel borsuk en profite pour se retirer
dans son havre de paix
c'est loin de la salle d'opération et de
la frénésie du milieu hospitalier que
nous l'avons rencontré donc ça fait déjà
quelques mois que la greffe facial a eu
lieu donc une première au canada
commencé leur retour à la vie normale
après une expérience aussi intense que
celle là c'est pas une retour normal
c'était c'était une expérience très
intense je pense pour tout le monde qui
était là et ça prend du temps alors
c'est toujours dans tes temps dépensée
un greffe de visage c'est pas juste un
organe en grève plus qu'il ya une
identité qui greffent ia et la façon
qu'on dirait interagissent avec le monde
de la façon que le monde interagit avec
nous c'est par notre visage
alors qu'est ce que la greffe et si
c'était plus que ça
c'est très spirituel il ya plusieurs
moments pendant l'expérience que que tu
réalises que tu fais plus que juste une
chose je veux juste que justin young
ouverte
[Musique]
la greffe de visage ne sauve pas de vie
c'est pas comme un coeur un fois pour
vous qu'est ce que ça représente quand
même énorme et ça ça sauve une vie
d'avoir une vie et de vivre c'est là
c'est différent
tu peux être en vie mais pas venir et
c'était le cas de maurice c'est ça il
était en vie mais s'est pas inquiété
c'est quand même pas de qualité de vie
c'est pas lui alors ça sauve pas de vie
comme tel comme une fois ne rien car
poumons mais ça ça sauve une vie commune
est ce que vous avez appris des choses
sur vous comme chirurgien pas comme
chirurgien comme être humain oui tu
quand tu es mis dans des circonstances
plus extrêmes tu vois comment tu réagis
je vois que des îlots tu es capable
d'accomplir des défis ou de réussir les
défis que tu aies jamais rêvé à qui
était possible
[Musique]
daniel borsuk n'était pas destiné à
manipuler le bistouri en fait la
médecine ne l'avait jamais attiré j'ai
tombé en amour avec la médecine un peu
par accident
quand j'étais en train de faire mon
évier amiguet alors je tenais aussi à
l'opération tout en habit parce que
j'étais au même biais pas prêt pour la
salle d'opération pilager rentrée je
vois une broche qui est en train d'être
attaché et j'ai capoté
c'est incroyable qu'à partager les nerfs
les temps dans l'eau si j'étais
tellement fixé sur sa c'était comme une
une vraie moment comme serait une
révélation c'est une vraie révélation
dans lorsqu'en j'ai retourné chez nous
jeudi mais la frégate finances où j'ai
dit je veux faire mon métier de médecine
et je vais terminer mon mb pendant 1 ce
que j'avais fait
donc j'ai terminé mes cours de mba
pendant médecine loges avec l'intention
de rentrer un show du plastique parfaite
la reconstruction est là alors c'est le
parcours est là on est ici aujourd'hui à
2012 donc vous avez déjà participé à une
grève faciale très importante aux états
unis
vous étiez le seul canadien présent dans
l'équipe c'est quoi le contexte il a
permis donc de vous joindre à cette
équipe là c'est grâce docteur rodriguez
j'étais son fellow j'étais étudiant est
en train d'être ni chirurgie
craniofaciale chirurgie plastique pour
la phase avec lui
puis il a eu ce projet là pendant des
années et il m'a invité d'être sur son
équipe
[Musique]
et j'étais chanceux d'être là pendant
qu'on avait fait qu'il était on était
une équipe de cinq chirurgiens et c'est
vraiment grâce à lui cessé lui un des
groupes pionniers dans le monde pour la
greffe à sierre
à tout juste 40 ans daniel tour ce qui
fait déjà partie du cercle restreint des
spécialistes en grès faciale rien
surprenant à la fin de sa résidence
en 2011 il remportait le prix du
meilleur spécialiste parmi tous les
finissants en chirurgie plastique au
canada depuis il carbure aux défis de
choses qui nous motive c'est de est
capable de pousser les limites de ses
anciens si on peut aider le monde plus
possible il faut toujours envie
d'essayer de pousser des choses on peut
pas rester assis et rien faire alors
c'est sûr que notre équipe en super en
prenant des meilleures équipes au monde
pour en train de faire ça puis on a des
autres travaillent travaux à faire dans
le même domaine
comme québécois je pense important pour
nous d'être pas en arrière des autres on
est double
puis il faut rester là faut que en garde
si tu estimes de tous ces villes de m et
c'est ce que vous allez faire pousser
les limites en s on espère
[Musique]